over the years batman has more than
earned his place in pop culture legend
and for more reasons than one he boasts
a remarkable rogues gallery he's a key
player in super teams like the justice
league and he's a merchandising
juggernaut to boot and of course you
can't ignore arguably the most important
aspects of batman's iconic appeal the
bat suit as long as there's been a
batman there's been a bat suit in some
form or fashion some are cloth and some
are rubber some are armored and some are
lightweight they come in a range of
color schemes ear and cape lengths and
utility belt sizes regardless of the
specifics though batman rarely leaves
the batcave without one his suits go a
long way in keeping him safe and they
help strike beer into the hearts of
gotham city's criminals what gives you
the right what's the difference between
you and me i'm not wearing hockey pads
still as badass as many of batman's
costumes may be the truth is they're far
from perfect and if you place them into
a real world context some serious issues
begin to present themselves arguably one
of the most glaring problems has even
been examined by physicists who
explained why a bat suit wouldn't work
in real life as it does in the comics
cartoons or movies any batman fan will
tell you that most bat suits are
incomplete without a cape after all they
don't call him the caped crusader for
nothing on the surface the cape seems
like little more than an aesthetic
choice but in truth many batman
incarnations have used it for much more
than looking good aside from using it as
a means of intimidation against gotham
criminals it has often been used as a
method of gliding across large distances
and while this may look cool on the
silver screen or in the pages of a comic
book the truth is that this function
isn't nearly as plausible in reality
back in 2012 physicists at the
university of leicester published a
study in the journal of special physics
topics it read clearly gliding using a
bat cape is not a safe way to travel
unless a method to rapidly slow down is
used such as a parachute they noted that
after leaping from a 150 meter high
gotham city skyscraper batman could
realistically glide for approximately
350 meters on a 4.7 meter wingspan
before the velocity levels off at 110
kilometers per hour at that point an 80
kilometer per hour descent would begin
causing the dc comics mainstay to
plummet to his death unless he found
something to break his fall still
there's nothing wrong with pretending
that batman can use his cape to glide
from building to building it's a fun
mechanic to use in the batman arkham
video games for example and it sets up
some neat visuals on the big screen but
there's one other aspect of the suit
that's even less practical than the cape
a cowl specifically those worn by the
likes of michael keaton and his
successors for their live-action movie
appearances seeing as these specific
cowls consisted of one solid piece from
the shoulders up it would be incredibly
difficult for batman to turn his head in
fact this has even caused problems
during filming on batman movies in the
past at a 2014 press event michael
keaton discussed his struggles with the
headpiece while filming 1989's batman
revealing that moving his head at the
neck was next to impossible as a result
he had no choice but to move his entire
upper body for moments in which batman
had to turn and look in a different
direction that's obviously inconvenient
for an actor let alone someone trying to
fight off two or three bad guys at once
from cape to cowl the batsuit is
something of a mess by real world
standards and it's typically presented
as the ultimate suit of armor at the
cinema on tv and in the pages of dc
comics at the end of the day though
suspension of disbelief is the name of
the game with stuff like this as long as
it looks cool that's all that really
matters
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you